[Music]
i attended
a jewish school audacious oil and
berliners did my sister
most of the time we were very aware of
the fact that we live in dangerous times
on the corner before we went to
synagogue
it's the custom for father to bless his
children
and i remember all the years that i can
think back that when my father blessed
my sister and me
he always cried and i assumed
that it was
because they knew
small as you were you you realized that
and of course we were confronted daily
daily
with the swastika and the hordes
and in the glass cases on the street
corners
the display of the sturmer
my father would sometimes pick one up in
a train and bring it home
so there was this feeling of
an impending doom
he was taken away very early in the
morning my mother was crying and
there was such to do that my sister and
i woke up and we went to see what was
going on
and i remember the policeman saying as
far as he knows that they're
being deported to poland and
that's the last time i saw my father
when castaner came it was a disaster
and it became clear that life for jews
in germany was
all over
[Music]
decisions had to be made as to who
should go
and who should not go for example
one of my uncles and decided not to send
both of their children they would send
one child to test the waters
and keep one child with them
to see if this would work because there
was no certainty it was
actually fought with danger and we're
made aware of the fact that we will be
carrying a luggage tag in our lapel and
all it would say
is the name and the district and
building which we live no street
nothing else no identity and that we
were to act as though we didn't know
from where we came
we left in the morning early in the
morning it was time so that we would get
to the border at night
because we needed the cover of darkness
of course i remember leaving from
barnhuft saw
and i remember that not about a minute
or two out of bonhoeffer
on the elevated tracks of the railroad
came into view the hull
of this burned and destroyed famous
synagogue of berlin fazan strasse
and that was the last stab in the heart
for a little jewish boy
to see the burnt hug of this famous
synagogue
i also remember very well that my mother
took me into a corner in this railroad
compartment
i remember well what she said to me
in order to make sure i understood
because of course i was a little boy
very attached to my mother it was a
great love relationship
in that little speech in the train
i always say i became bar mitzvah i have
not been formally my mitzvah when i was
13 i was not permitted
i was permitted when i was 11 by my
mother
no minion no rabbi i was given my my
orders my commandments
as to what to do and i remember that
i was to be the hero of the family and
toughest design to be courageous
and so the journey took it took its last
hour or two
at the station as we got off the train
uh my mother said to me you must not try
you must turn must not turn around
and look back and you must not try and
she did not kiss me good luck goodbye
because there was just no time
we we went to the left we children and i
remember my mother and the other lady
turned to the light
and that was the last we saw them that
was december the 6th 1938
in the middle of the night
[Music]
i remember having to go to a
photographer
in jorge fein to have pictures taken i
still have those pictures in the little
dutch folder
at home and uh we got to england
and that was of course the last i saw my
sister who unfortunately perished in
[Music]
belt